bien ri en attendant en attendant que
ces trois chefs s'installe je vais
présenter donc les les autres par nino
dominant
pas dire des choses vous voulez dire
quelque chose mais ma jeunesse à mieux
alors que je voulais dire et puis alors
nous sommes des cheminots de la gare de
lyon qui sont venus vous rendre visite
vous êtes la gare de lyon ils viennent
d'avoir des crèmes toute la semaine et
je pense qu'il est normal que cheminot
viennent expliquer un peu puisque vous
êtes en train bleu un restaurant de luxe
et bien nous pouvons peut-être parler de
nos salaires puisque nous revendiquons
le salaire nous aimerions aussi que
passer en direct sur l'écran parce que
nous aimerions que les chaînes que les
usagers que les téléspectateurs
connaissent nos revendications
oui nous aimerions savoir que nous
demandant le salaire minimum de 1000
francs en moi car il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui connu un agent du niveau
1 depuis par niveau de l'exécution ne
gagne pas c'est sans faute en moi il
faut savoir qu'au niveau des gens
qualifiés du niveau de 2009 non plus un
agent qui peut avoir quatre ans
d'ancienneté qui peut avoir trois ans
d'apprentissage au centre saint siège ne
les gagne pas il faut le savoir tout
cela
nous sommes venus le dire nous sommes
venus dire qu'on me demande s ata
d'euros annuels pendant vos gens sont
encore s'en faut nous avons passé 1 4 po
on y fait cheminots sont à notre
beaucoup de congés bien là on s'aperçoit
que ce n'est pas vrai gens venus
protester
ouais d'accord avait coûté voilà c'est
chose faite et c'est bien
la vente met 300 nous avons encore
beaucoup de choses à dire non mais bien
sûr enfin vous pourrez pas tous les
jours la haine envers une chose que le
trouver ce qui s'est passé s'est passé
gentil pourra dès que j'en système bien
bon défi
non
alors
robert lambert courts fines on dit
courtine maintenant chroniqueur
gastronomique aussi célèbre sous le nom
de porte inox votre pseudonyme de la
reynière et vous aime les autos nombreux
ouvrages notamment le cahier des
recettes va l'amener grec paru aux
éditions laffont
j